this morning we have a story about a
national park in east africa and a group
of young women turning traditional
gender roles upside down the park is
home to a majestic variety of wildlife
it borders the home
of the maasai one of the few african
tribes that still maintain
traditional customs as deborah patta
shows us the woman known as
team lioness are helping the animals
and their community it's early morning
and everyone is already up the men tend
cattle
the women's job is to milk them
everyone knows their place but today the
routine's been disrupted
team lioness has arrived but these
rangers are not working
they've come bearing gifts their
colleague ruth cicata has just had a
baby
and they have big plans for little
newborn beatrice
team lion cub
twenty-four-year-old purity lakara
cuddles baby beatrice
she knows if she had not become a ranger
motherhood was
all her future would have held women's
are only allowed to stay at home
looking after their kids and giving
birth we are not meant to stay just at
home no
we were educated to come and change the
world so that's what we are doing right
now
together with her seven teammates she
was selected for kenya's first
all-female anti-poaching squad
set up by the international fund for
animal welfare
but ifos east africa director james
essiece explains
it was a tough pitch to the local elders
this
community the maasai community is a very
patriarchal
community where the men have all the say
in fact it's uh we faced quite an uphill
task
convincing the man to allow us to
to recruit team lioness these
trailblazing women
serve as the first line of defense
against poaching
they are trading and coming back and
matching
the men or the male rangers good for
boots
the work is physically grueling they
patrol the maasai community land that
surrounds the amboseli national park
often walking 12 miles a day animal
siting
12th grand gazelle but being female
gives them an advantage maasai women
might appear
invisible to their men but they hear
everything that's going on in their
community
including who is illegally killing
animals for bushmeat
and they feel far more comfortable
talking to team lioness than their male
counterparts
it's just a secret between you and the
person who feeds you with the
information
then we put an ambush we caught him
without him knowing that we are aware of
what he
or she is doing through these tip-ups
they've reduced poaching and the
retaliatory killing of animals by 80
percent
since the unit was launched in 2019
and as for the men who mocked them the
respect that they used to give to men
they are now giving us that respect
nobody
is laughing now team lioness has been so
successful that there are plans to
recruit more women from the messiah
community
and to roll out similar anti-poaching
squads elsewhere
for cbs this morning deborah patter risa
kenya
deborah thank you we are not meant to
stay home but we are educated and come
to change the world while changing the
world they are